welcome to this video against hubba
hubba from Norway it's all just a
conspiracy maybe yeah well not maybe not
all there are maybe some conspiracies
but probably less than people believe ok
so the sloth let's do the main line and
see what is playing capturing on c4 a
forum on on this caption or a 60 is six
what am I playing here I can try that
that didn't claim much of this move this
is mixing ideas of the slab and the
Catalan um is this why they take I
cannot remember that check 95 now or how
is this plate I don't know all night II
393 I ok let's play I have to really
invent the theory here for me
experimenting a little bit with a form
this looks this looks kind of normal
so see doing King is 70 probably
yeah probably King e7 and other moves
look a bit strange all right strange as
a strong word but looks kind of normal
okay so he allows this check and that
this surprising or Bishop to 2d six
takes Knight things and then I will
check their chat it it looks more
promising to get the bishops actually
ose planking is some 9-piece check
that's funny oh maybe I overlooked
something Bishop t to Bishop to Bishop
did she has rugby aid and after takes
Knight eggs ah oh oh that that said
sensing that will hurt now I didn't know
that was to quickly play he's got book
bed now I only was thinking about
capturing Andrew p8 but Luke b8
immediately if I take on before yes I
get the c5 square but he will take with
the night and he has night c2 that's the
problem ah what a bad mistake what a bad
mistake
wow is it somewhere someway to swingle
swingle here before maybe I don't know I
I it was very very stupid should have
thought about this a little bit more
okay okay so at least at least maybe I'm
not losing a big material now I get the
d6 square for my night at least it's not
not a not a whole exchange or look or
what whatever it was I mean it's still a
bad position but okay I have to take
with the night right not it's not very
nice but what can you do yeah I so lamb
and now night see why I guess and it's
got 93 check okay he's got the check on
check on c3
yeah I'd see if we check let's look that
looks kind of sick I know but it's a
it's a bad position in any case
I didn't even see that didn't see that
at all check check
no no it's not even even so I'm sorry
some City trick or anything he just
totally totally lost check f6 a thought
but ok this is this is enough as well be
five chicks check it check them oh wow
that was a bad game check check I mean
bad gamer they're badly played by me
this is what I'm trying to say a bad
game some more implies that he also made
some mistakes which might be true but
maybe he could have killed me more
efficiently but we was just just
completely rotten this position ok I
just have one little idea Knight a5
rookie 7 this is the the final final a
little idea
our rookie seven which is not going to
help really check night f5 Luke g7 mate
unfortunately it's relatively easy to
prevent any anyways to still get this in
probably not and he can just take on g4
o check I mean it's still lost hi it's
his directly promoting white resigns
yeah yeah it was it was just a bad play
in the opening here this this thing with
96 I should have thought about a little
bit yeah i was thinking bishop d6 on 96
and yeah yeah just simply I simply
didn't think about it clearly I mean
here I can still go back and sort of
hang on but taking on b7 is just bad
young I forgot that he can play rugby 8
or forgot I overlooked him that he can
play rugby AIDS immediately and I was
just saying he will take and then I can
go back to see five and then it's a
normal position but here I'm really lost
I mean him probably could have done
something better here and I t7s much
better it prevents be five with a tempo
and here I'm sort of chap still hanging
on but it is very bad of course I'm
losing a pawn and yeah Bishop takes d5
look sick but what are you going to do
here yeah it was just a big blunder in
the opening I have two to do something
else they have Bishop t6 or maybe not
Bishop f4 in the first place like like
this and then say normal position black
is fairly solid
of course if he goes like i can play 94
or castles i mean this is this is pretty
pretty okay fine but the way I played it
mounted to a to suicide okay well thanks
for watching